[Music]
jacob
sorry buddy you're not going come on
[Music]
all right guys you ready to drive 16
hours to louisiana
yes oh it's gonna be a long trip
[Music]
me
well it took about 17 hours of driving
but we're here morgan city louisiana and
it is a hot humid drizzly day
and very soon my friend's going to meet
us right here at the dock and we're
going to go into the bayou
and we're going to spend five days
hunting frogs
fishing camping eating good food it's
going to be amazing
all right this is stafford with cajun
experience we went with these guys
about what two years ago three years
three years ago he's going to take us
out to our houseboat deep into the bayou
and we're going to have a great time
guys
we're heading out to the house but we're
just going to take a little look-see at
a crab pot
okay you got that we got it all right
it's going to be heavy now
see what we got let's see what we got oh
that's a nice blue crab
that's actually for this area that's a
medium sized crab oh that's
that's a very nice medium no we gotta
leave the crab in we're gonna come back
get him cheese he'll bring his friends
drop it yep toss it all right all right
oh i just got stuck in the face that's
my money maker i can't be swell it up
as long as i can charge it each day i
should be fine
oh yellow kai i guess she got it she
knows how to do all this
okay but when i see it
these guys here at cajun experience have
an awesome setup check this out we got
these
two houseboats anchored up here in this
eating area
in between and check out the guest boat
here we've got
this nice area here got a full bathroom
little living area kitchen
okay another bathroom
got a whole bunch of bunk beds
ac this is awesome me and the boys are
gonna be living like
kings this week me and tommy came here
three years ago
and stayed one night just had the time
of our lives and i've been chomping at
the bit to get back here
ever since so now we're bringing nathan
we're going to be here for four whole
nights
uh it's just gonna be awesome what do
you got there
this is the bottom jaw of 156 pound
alligator gore
look at the monster teeth on that it's
like little teeth upon big
teeth more teeth yes i would like to
catch one of those
yeah we definitely go after some garf
this is just a
eight or five pounder it's a baby right
that's your souvenir man amy how was
that tommy is that pretty cool
oh tommy look at this what'd you find
daddy big bertha
look at her yeah she is a beauty
it's a little rainy you got some
lightning coming in we're just gonna
take it easy maybe eat some dinner
and uh when it clears up we're gonna
venture out
oh this is this is so nice
i think uh i think dinner is going to be
very nice
this is the cajun dinner of champions
here we've got fried
alligator and we got seafood stew on
rice and there's also some white beans
around but i ate them all so
any rate this is delicious what'd you
eat
dirty or nice did you like it yes it
tasted
it's the delicious nice i ever ate i'm
going to show you some
dance moves
oh yeah yeah you're brave dancing now
you got the music and the music's in you
well i got a belly full of cajun food
and the sun is setting we're going to
let it get properly dark and me and the
boys
are gonna be doing some frogging it's
gonna get your frogging lights on
are you guys super excited to go
frogging yeah
we're just cruising around the bayou
here with these headlamps
and you start seeing all these eyes
all the little spiders and creepy
crawlies their eyes shine in the dark
when you're wearing these headlamps
and we're looking for a set of big
whitish bluish lies
that belong to a bullfrog oh yeah yeah
he is yeah he's right there
come up here get up on the front look at
him he's just sitting right on the log
okay what we're gonna do and come
in oh daddy i just saw baby flog
it was this tiny oh you saw a baby frog
now i don't know if you people at home
can see this
but there's these little blue specks all
over
in the swamps those are spider eyes
those are big old swamp spiders
staring back at us and it's hard to tell
the difference between giant spider eyes
and frog eyes
see look there's there's the spiders
running on top of the water
oh look at this spider this spider
jumping on the water
oh there's an alligator over there oh
yeah look at that gargoyle yeah look
right there in the middle everywhere
oh there's one right there i wanted to
move murphy because all that rain
tommy this is all you buddy right here
look at look at our lights go get him
you got him you go oh
[Music]
little forward one foot
[Music]
got him i finally got it okay
there we go we got one in the basket
[Music]
oh get him nathan get him watch him
until you get him oh he is a big boy
grab him oh wow that's cool oh he's a
soccer team
oh he's he's staying naughty where he's
ain't potty
no you get that make that noise
high five nathan let's see let's see if
we can see the difference so he's a
bullfrog right
see the leopard print oh yeah okay okay
and he this little guy's a yellow throat
see how
it's yellow right there a little yellow
right here the bigger ones you can tell
a lot about he's white
right yeah grab them
i got him i got it got him you got him
whoa
he spotted it and caught it joey look at
that you got that all by yourself that's
awesome buddy
look at that toe pincher right there a
toe pincher
here check it out oh i got him
oh he's got he's crawling underneath it
look at that
oh you got him go ahead and put that in
there
lean way over and go quick with both
hands
[Music]
nathan you having fun no because the
frog's got away
as long as you don't give up you're
going to catch something you know what
i'm never giving
never giving up okay
here nate nathan you got to practice
okay you ready get him come on
you can get him get him you'll get him
oh wait we got to get him come on
get him come on boy turn your lightness
off
oh you got a one-handed put them in the
basket put them in the basket can i get
a high five too
got him pull it in pull it down
[Music]
you want to practice on a big one here
go get it he's a big boy
[Music]
hey that's his ninja swipe good i'll put
him in the basket right behind you
knock it out go get him oh your ninja
swiped him
he found him and grabbed him all by
herself good one nate
oh there we go yeah oh he's a pretty
decent sized one get him
oh get him you got him got him buddy got
him
look at that that's a great one tom you
got him
oh look
look at that there's a pile of frogs big
spider coming towards us
oh oh that's on my camera it's on my
camera nathan you having a good time
good well guys i don't even know what
time it is but it is
late and we've got about 20 frogs in our
cage
we've put hands on another 20 more and
uh
we've just had a bulb all right tommy
wants to keep this one as a pet
he's only he's missing one leg he's a
[Music]
pirate
go to sleep we got a lot of things to
catch tomorrow
oh tommy's been awake for about five
minutes
and his pet frog has already escaped
from the jar and hid under the oven
dad he got extra what oh my goodness
ethan you asked me ken that's not true
nathan hey check this out see he caught
a snapping turtle that had eggs in her
when they
ate the snapping turtle they put the
eggs in here and they're going to hatch
them yep then we're going to charm loose
oh did miss cavalier give you something
nice yeah it's a buffalo
oh yeah you can actually bring that one
home and mama won't complain
the one i call it be one with the frog
the frog is with me yeah pretty cool do
you know
is that your frog from yesterday no it
might be
that is a hefty amount of frogs that's
heavy
nathan look she's got she's got a pet
jar
oh you boys i mean he's the smallest one
in the cage and he looks massive
i got a belly full of sausage and
biscuits and me and stafford we're gonna
run the boat out
um just do a few errands check on a few
things
and uh we'll bring the cast net along
just in case something uh catches our
eye we'll get some more bait
we'll be right back don't catch all my
crawfish now
he's the leader he's all business we're
gonna get ourselves a little bit of bait
and i'm going to see if i'm any good
with this cast net here
got three of these little baby mullet
i'm swimming
right there you go look nice catch there
look at this
all right that's the garbage right there
that bigger one oh yeah
that's about as tall as you want but
yeah i threw one on clean out the boat
they're everywhere
well there we go guys just caught my
first buffalo with the trip
you got a [ __ ] oh
you got a few things see look i caught a
large mouth
now it's a five pounder look at that
uh got some decent gizzard shad yeah
yeah got ourselves a nice bucket of bait
hi you guys having the best trip ever
yeah oh my goodness
last time we came here it was a little
earlier in the year and we did a lot of
crawfishing and these
are the crawfish traps these things are
awesome and they're really easy to make
all right this is a crawfish bait right
here it's lunchtime and we got a cage
full of frogs so it's time to cook up
some frog legs
oh you're getting the big bertha yeah i
like big benzy
big yeah here's a frog stomach let's see
what's in there
that looks like a crawfish to me doesn't
it
that's what it is favorite food oh that
is a pile of
frog legs and it is this really soft
meat right here
man
now we're gonna cook these things up
oh my goodness we've got a frog leg
feast here
tell me what do you think of frog legs
good
frog legs really do taste like chicken
but it's
softer than chicken and it's i think
it's better than chicken
it's really good stuff i don't think
you'll ever find anyone bad mouth and
frog legs whoa
we're getting the full caging experience
here
we gotta we're gonna soak you up
there you go buddy tell us how to stop
using my fish baits to take baths away
okay
thomas this is his catfish bait
so yeah this is what they used to catch
catfish in the hoop nets it's
ivory soap yeah food is full of water
we had thunder we had lightning crazy
rain and about
15 minutes later we got blue skies look
at that
it helps you hook the bait better with
the hook we always get rid of the bottom
half
like so this would be crappy and this
will be for trot lines right
outlines jug lines stuff like that all
right got jug lines here
i don't get to go these are alligator
guard jug lines
oh yeah we got to make some new ones
all right guys we've got a belly full of
frog we're going to go out and do a
little gar
fishing and maybe catch some carp as
well
so we're busting out the fishing gear
let's see what happens
we're juggling for catfish got that pool
noodle
with the weight and a little bit of hook
and some bait
and we'll come back a couple hours see
if we don't have a catfish
are you still having fun yeah awesome
the storm's eased up just a little bit
we're gonna try to go
around it and find a better place to go
do some fishing
looks a little bit clearer out there
[Music]
you got something to protect you from
the rain there all right
oh that's a big one there you go this is
like cajun sia over here
[Music]
all right guys we're gonna be jug lining
for gar here big
alligator guard so we got a whole mullet
pull the baiter out put the fish on the
line
and you don't have an anchor on these no
angle so so the ropes are long enough to
touch the bottom right hey tom and hey
do you know what these are for
giant gar they get over 100 pounds here
bigger than me and tommy put together
there you go perfect yeah drop it
perfect
okay check that nate chuck it throw it
hard quick good job
okay nathan
there you go
[Music]
oh those are called silver carp or big
head carbs some people call them asian
carb
but they're not really carb at all
they're more related to a minnow
but they taste like crappie they're
really good
you're bringing all your lily pads yummy
of course you
are well it feels good to be in some dry
clothes and we are looking forward to
dinner
oh my goodness look at that and these
are
golden balls balls all right here's
buddha balls booty balls
booty balls some frogs no you didn't say
it right not even close
all right we got some boude balls and uh
we got some frog legs
and some toast and we got some beans and
potatoes
the way you make these boutique balls is
basically you stew up
a pork butt you take some green peppers
yellow peppers red peppers onions celery
you stew it up really good you take the
moisture off of it add some rice
mix it all up then bread it deep fry it
toast
potatoes life jackets coming off this
dance party got serious
oh for dessert we got homemade ice cream
this is what we call aggressive churn
this is how louisiana men
make ice cream there with the power
drill thank you
well we're dry well fed and the boys are
enjoying some ice cream so we're gonna
go out
and try to catch a gar maybe some carp
we're gonna check the jug lines we've
got rod and reels we even got spears
here
and we're going to try to do as much as
we can before the weather chases us off
because we have
a small bit of clear on the doppler and
a whole lot more of that rain is coming
our way all right we're going to hit our
catfish jugs first
check those out yeah that one ain't
doing much
i grabbed this right no you just you
don't never have to touch the fish you
see it coming right off
there you go little chum there right yep
well we got that one channel cat and
tomorrow we'll check it again with the
boys
it's not pouring buckets it's not
blowing a gale
we're gonna see what happens this chum
has been sitting for a day or so and
it's gotten a little bit more like
play-doh
there we go
we're going to blast out some rigs for
alligator gar out this direction
well we've got four carp rods bombed out
that direction to where we've been
chumming
it's got a bonk right there on that one
little ticket attack
that's about oh yeah yeah yeah
something's on there
there we go look at look at his belly
buddy
crushed sweet corn in his mouth that one
there will become
feelings
[Music]
off of memory right so remember what
it's about you got it
all right we're throwing out a couple
more alligator guard jugs and uh before
we head back to that lake where we saw
those
asian carp we're gonna see if we can't
spear spear some of those
yeah we got a real fish poker right
there
it's pinned to the bottom so let's let's
see if there's a fish on it
check this guy out y'all
look at that that's a nice clean shot
grab that and see what how much force it
takes to pop him off there
that's stuck pretty good pretty good all
right we got one
all right i nicked him but i missed him
oh there the guard right there
oh nope he spotted guard right right
ahead
he's holding really steady oh steady you
gonna
you hear that no way take this guy out
look at that
yeah it holds it right yeah it holds it
all right just speared my second car in
the search for a carp
continues
oh missed
oh wait oh dang it
oh dang it
oh oh
what about put myself in the water going
after that gizzard chad
riding around earlier yeah oh hold up
oh i nosed him oh
oh there's the gar
right right through the center
oh dang it
[Music]
whoa big head carve come up and hit my
spear
oh i heard him i heard him hold
oh look at the thick body on that guy oh
hey that's a baby around here yeah
i think we're having buffalo ribs
so this right here is a smallmouth
buffalo it's a native fish here it's
related to a sucker it's not
actually a carp though they eat the same
thing carps do
and they act a lot like carp but the way
you tell they're not carp
beside the fact that they're kind of
silver instead of gold
as you look right over here they've got
no whiskers
a carp has kind of these fu manchu
whiskers
this guy's got nothing a little the
bottom looks kind of heart-shaped just
like a sucker because he's a he's a
member of the sucker family
and he looks a lot like a quillback
sucker or a carp sucker
but uh awesome fish i actually might go
home and smoke some gar
but look at these gar oh man
this has been so much fun but it is
crazy late
it's like 1am and i think our plan was
to get up at 6 to go garfish
god oh
yeah but i think we better get home i
think we better head back to bed now
guys i cannot describe how much fun i'm
having on this trip i
i've absolutely dreamt of coming back
here so i wanted to do a little gift for
for stafford for showing us such a good
time so i'm giving him
two of my spears here this is the one i
hand
forged last year and the one i made this
year
and i'm going to leave them here with
them and if you guys want to come
and spear some fish i want to make sure
stafford has some spears so you guys
could do this too
but it is 1am i got to go to bed i'll
see you guys
in the morning staying up until like 2
a.m last night
is kicking my butt but it's 8 a.m and
the boys are up and they're well rested
so
that's good mommy you got to eat
something other than bacon okay
eat that i'll eat the sandwich with
butter
well we're done with breakfast and we
need to go check some jug lines
and uh it's rainy so uh we better get
geared up
geared up noodle trap
that's for punching your dad in the
crotch
[Music]
you you high-fived him oh that's a big
one
look look he's up in a tree you get him
tom oh
this is all you man
there we go
[Music]
i think i think you're wet
congratulations mate yeah you got him
first channel catfish of the day tommy
this guy right here
a blue catfish tail here's a big one
this is a good one
yeah stanford see this guy over here is
commercial catfisherman we're gonna go
over and say hi
how y'all doing these hoop nets are like
those little play place tunnels you go
in and you never come out you know
whoa you got a lot of them
both of the alligator guard jugs in his
leg have disappeared so we're just
cruising around
looking for him that's what happened
come on
oh he twitched a little bit let's see
what happens to the bait look comes up
the line
yeah see any skills on that you're right
all the skills on the side come off
every time hello easy easy watch it be
careful
i don't don't lean over the side just
drink it
right that's that's you whoa that's a
baby
that's a little one that's not even
that's a baby that's a
15 pounder not a baby girl call the baby
guard if you put your hand anywhere
right here and he moves it will cut you
oh
you just gotta rub your hand on the
outside and he will cut you yeah yeah
his
teeth are so sharp see these are these
little parasites see
oh it is garlic on oh yeah there we go
you call it garlic that's why i'm
calling him now i just made it up
look at that they look like a little
tiny skate tommy said he's super jealous
that you've got to catch that
alligator guard i'm super i'm jealous
[Music]
all right guys we got a big mess of
catfish in that alligator gar we're
gonna clean them up and that's to make
some good food
i'm going to take the shell off the back
right
all right step one you have to get in
between the scales
i think this is how it's done there you
go
one half where are you going there you
go it's not bad for a little fish
you guys scream and that's going to keep
that meat from breaking down like the
same way beaufin does
so the meat is always trying to break
down now yeah yeah i see they haven't
been dead
long gar a lot like bowfin their meat
breaks down as soon as the fish dies
so you want to clean and play it right
away and what he did is he scrapes the
meat with his blade to get kind of the
enzymes
and the bad meat off and then you don't
wash it off okay you put it in the bag
and freeze it dry
and that seems to help prevent the
enzymes from breaking the meat down too
quickly
a little higher
more than one way to skin a cat right
we're gonna fill in one side huh
like that see then we're gonna cut it
off cleaned up
gonna scrape the tail and we're gonna
flip him over
we're gonna put a couple of slits in him
and he's ready to fry you could eat
everything but the bone
we used to do this as kids this is this
would be money to go to local factory
and skin fish right
and today i'd probably lose buddy but
those young guys pretty good
go put those catfish in the crab pot and
we're gonna catch some blue crab too
guys
all right we're gonna clean and cook up
that buffalo we caught last night i'm
using the word we
very very loosely
[Music]
yeah look at that that is good looking
there you go there's one bone in here
right in the middle see it there you go
you fry it just like that
yeah pull the bone up nice
we're gonna eat some lunch and we've got
ourselves pasta layer
and fried garfish balls hey eat your
pasta laya you come eat your pazzalaya
and we have gar balls
this is like garden nuggets oh what what
do you think of that you like that
spicy it's spicy i can stand it
you can stand it nathan you like nathan
like that ice cream
don't mind me i saw him filling up this
big tub full of water and i
wonder if he's doing a crawfish boil you
don't use the bayou water because you
don't want everything turning brown
right
it is wet and rainy it has just been on
and off so it's just gonna be me and
staff are gonna go out and we're gonna
catch some blue crabs
[Music]
give it a little slack gotta hit bottom
holy mackerel these are jumbo crabs
[Music]
holy mackerel those are jumbo crabs
look at the size of this guy that guy
could sit on my dinner plate and pick up
the glass with one claw and the knife
and fork with the other cloth
look at that
i've caught blue crabs in virginia
delaware
maryland florida and those are the
biggest blue crabs i've ever seen
[Music]
[Music]
this is awesome
oh
i don't think i've ever had so much fun
throwing a net
this is absolutely insane check
this out
do we have enough bait i think we're
good buddy i think we're good i think we
got your bait situation taken care of
for the year
look at the size of these
[Music]
i got big [ __ ] crawfish crap and gar for
the next
six months
how about crabs we did pretty well for
crabs by my opinion i gotta scoot my way
to the front here
pleasure to meet you randy all right
catching them is the easy part now i
gotta get them all frozen and taxes away
hey where where would you uh it's
stafford there's a scale on your boat
right right there where my light is
there's a little slimy spot there
you know how to dirty a boat i know how
to mess a boat up so
quick
the type of fish that you got enough
bait we do have enough bait
we have a bait well after a long day
of throwing a cast net we've got deep
fried garfish patties
baked catfish white beans corn rice
i am gonna sleep like a log tonight
you just fed you just fed your frog corn
here take your frog we need to get some
sleep i'm exhausted
i'll see you guys in the morning
look at this what a beautiful way to
wake up in the morning
right here in the bayou i'm really sad
today is our last full day
tomorrow morning we head back
where's tommy ah there he is
hey nathan all right guys let's go get
some breakfast
oh
[Music]
tonight me and the boys are doing a
survival camp out
we are going to go and hike into the
swamp with all the leeches and
alligators and cottonmouths we're gonna
camp out in the swamp tonight so
i've got a really quick pack up some
stuff into my backpack and uh
it's gonna be fun all right stafford's
busting out the burner we're gonna do a
crab boil yesterday
that looks like some sort of nightmare
with all the little feet sticking out
we were going to eat the crabs last
night but we got so distracted by the
mullet we didn't have time so we're
going to use one jaw
one one whole jar
yeah let it boil for 10 minutes shut it
off let it sit for about 15 and we'll
take them out
i can feel the heat coming off this
oh man a little bit
look at this plate of crabs
oh look at that beauty oh man i can't
believe you caught him he looked so fast
he was so fast
well guys we got a nice belly full of
crab now i mean the boys can do a little
survival camping staff is going to drop
us off
on the bayou and uh we'll see what
happens
here nathan grab the spears
i'll go get it oh here no
tom show me your frogs oh my goodness we
got a
we got a tree frog and a big old
chameleon
yeah yeah take your life because uh yeah
why'd you leave it
yeah exactly and you guys probably want
your spears right
yeah you get hungry don't eat your boys
now see ya
see you tomorrow oh boys look at this
is a banana spider a banana spider
oh those are the creepiest spiders and
there's so many of them
oh you want to see if he'll attack the
stick what do you think
is this swampy enough for us
all right follow me
you got your spears yeah okay
oh yeah we can see your alligator
yeah it gets it's it gets deep over here
alligator is that right yeah you just
swim underneath it
you guys follow yeah land hoe
all right guys we found ourselves a
little bit of high land
and uh there's some trees here that we
can start using to build camp
here it comes
[Music]
oh man the rain has brought the bugs out
but i've got the boys out of the rain
and under the tarp now i need to worry
about food
and man i just i i need something to
cook on
and a way to cook out of the rain and
out of the mud
i'm out here working on this shelter and
stafford comes up in his boat and says i
got something you need to see
holy mackerel
is not a buffalo that is a massive grass
carp
it's pretty fishy oh my goodness look at
this grass carp
i see it the biggest one of those i've
ever caught is
36. that one's pretty close to it that
one thing when that one's over
i think it was over there i think it's
over that was cool
catch one of those on a rod and reel man
yeah
all right there we go got it done
so we are gonna make fried frog
jambalaya
and i have a bag of four live yellow
throat frogs that mean the boys caught
last night with their bare hands
four frog legs in a pot all right we're
gonna put some cajun seasoning on these
uh
these frog legs the seasoning's making
the frogs twitch and jump
is that creepy
now we're gonna fry up a bunch of
vegetables
all right now we've got this cajun spicy
jambalaya mix here
just take it nice and careful you don't
want to fall off let's see
tommy you in here yeah up here nate you
in here
yeah i'm right here all right guys let's
see if we can get to sleep
right before i fell asleep i was in my
skivvies and i flipped my hammock
fell into the mud and i tore a hole in
the mosquito netting
and i had to jump out in my underwear
and
fix the mosquito netting fix the
platform fix the hammock
re-rig everything and the bugs
ate me alive because i only had bug
repellent on my arms and legs and so
i've got
dozens and dozens of bites where the sun
don't shine i
have been itching and itching and
itching all night long
arms and my back are just like bumpy
look at that he's biting me through my
shirt
oh man they're just thick
good morning tom nathan
good morning yeah we're live
we're live but we're about five pounds
lighter from all the blood we donated
i i've got i've got itches in places
that shouldn't be scratched
all right guys we're out of here bye
mosquitos
man i am so covered in bug bites oh my
arm oh look at that
holy crap that's a lot of bug bites
feels good to be clean and then fresh
clothes
it's our last day here and we're going
to be leaving in a few hours and i'm
sad to go this has just been awesome
this is our second trip
with cajun experience and it's not going
to be our last
every time you book with these guys it's
an exclusive experience there's no
mixing parties you get
the entire houseboat to yourself it's
just an amazingly affordable
and unique experience highly recommend
you guys check these guys out
before they figure out their
undercharging people and raise their
prices
this is a great deal
oh man guys we gotta come back with
grandpa don't we
yeah we're gonna see if we can catch
another giant
dummy this one's got a fish he is
moseying
we're heading back to the car and we're
just checking a few jugs
and sure enough there's something big on
this jug here
pull them up let's see what tom got
you're not lying all right tommy
smile jeez that's awesome
is that as big as nations there's a
little bigger i think
did you hear that we gotta get going to
the car and there's no room in the boat
so
we'll leave them there and come back and
release them later
guys was that a fun trip yeah man we
just had a ball we hope you guys enjoyed
this video as much as we enjoyed making
it
and don't forget to click subscribe to
the outdoor boys youtube channel we put
out new videos
every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching